what's the first thing we should see in
a movie or television trailer it has to
just be something that like provokes you
to keep watching really I mean it could
be a line of dialogue I guess or an
opening shot that's like you know what
is that like or if it's
um recognizable you can get away with it
like if it's IP I mean you can probably
do
um
kind of more creative ways into a
trailer because you know the audience is
already there right waiting for it
um I don't know if that's a uh because
it just depends on what it is that
you're cutting and what the style of it
even is like does it
um
yeah I think like generally it's just
let's just get into it with something
that uh that makes me want to keep
watching really that's the easiest way
to say it but it really is uh it could
be so many things depending on what it
is that you're cutting
how do you keep a movie trailer
interesting without revealing everything
but keeping it true to the film
um well okay so I have a lot of
experience doing promos which makes it a
lot easier than doing full trailers uh
there's a
um
a sort of a trailer format
you know like a theatrical trailer let's
call it that's anything that's like two
minutes let's say uh those are 90
seconds to two minutes those become a
little increasingly more difficult to
hold things back to sustain uh and I
think that's part of partially because
of what people are used to seeing these
days I think uh but promos like if
you're gonna you know if you're doing a
30 second spot on one you can definitely
do that in in
uh and they're way more fun in a way
because you get to actually kind of just
tease somebody to want to watch it
um whereas in like I I do find that
sometimes trailers give away everything
uh sometimes I don't care and sometimes
I really hate it it's just it it just
depends sometimes on the on the movie uh
but
you know I've heard a lot of people talk
about
um trailers just uh always doing this
always giving them boys things away and
like for instance for me I saw the
teaser of Dune and I refuse to watch
anything more because I know I'm gonna
go see it so maybe it's just give it up
to the to the audience to decide if they
need to see the if you know if they need
to see the full trailer or not to keep
them from being spoiled but I have to do
that myself so as a trailer editor
sometimes
how many trailers have you edited I
don't know 200 plus
maybe like when I say trailers really
what I mean is trailers promos and spots
because they're all related
and actually and if I really was going
to do throw cut Downs in from a full
trailer to a 30 then it probably would
be like you know even higher too so
uh yeah quite a few what's the average
length of the trailers or promos that
you edit most I would be I would say
um well okay promos are always going to
be 30 seconds sometimes they're 15s
everyone's want to get a 60.
um
trailers or 90s 90 seconds to two
minutes usually
and do you have a rule for how many
shots or frames or whatever you use
within those time no no I think it's
just
um
the the project that you're cutting will
inform the style and
well not always but mostly uh mostly
most of the time the the project you're
working on will inform you what kind of
approach you take to create that trailer
so if the film is slow
as in like a long burn then the trailer
is probably not going to be a fast paced
kind of trailer
um unless they're trying to disguise
something uh
the about that film or or trick an
audience into watching something that
it's not but that's never usually the
directive honestly
when you watch movie trailers do you
often feel that the trailer
misrepresents the film or doesn't do it
justice
um
that's a good question I think
uh I think most of the time
the trailers that you see
are going to be an amalgamation of five
different trailer editors who have cut
versions and then you're seeing one that
has all the best spots that the
executives have chosen to represent
right so it gets it gets tricky in that
sense
um
and then you know the other side of it
is is like well is that representative I
mean like The Suicide Squad trailer made
a big splash because it was awesome and
then they changed the movie to be more
like it so the story goes so that may
have something to do with that movies
um panning critically I don't uh I can't
speak to that because I wasn't involved
in that project but is it's it's
something that that uh like I would be
devastated if somebody cut a trailer of
my film that was awesome and maybe
different than what the movie was and
then I was asked to make the movie more
like the trailer I mean can you imagine
what that would probably feel like but
that's what they did with that film and
that just kind of shows you I guess like
that I don't know I mean like it's a
business at the end of the day and yeah
sometimes movies don't or the trailers
don't represent the films I think
oftentimes they probably do a decent job
of that honestly I mean there's always
going to be
examples either way though uh that do
one or the other
so I think there's a format that works
essentially in and maybe it's a little
too
uh calculated now these days but it does
the job and
um and if you see a really exceptional
trailer it's probably because it's doing
something different
Each decade there's a different style of
filmmaking would you say the same with
the trailers if we look back at trailers
from let's say the 70s it almost seems
like it's just one long scene from the
movie yeah yeah no of course definitely
um I also think that trailers are kind
of a unique place to really do some
creative editing
um it's a it I like to think that there
is an art they're just as much of an art
form as as
um you know anything else in a way
um
and I of course I think that because I
have like some experience working in
that side of the industry
um but like there's the uh Promax BDA
Awards which is mostly for promos and
spots and stuff that um but you go to
that and you see all of you know the
nominations and stuff and
and it's pretty cool to kind of get a
sense of like wow they really did some
crazy unique stuff for that show or like
this
um campaign or you know what I mean like
it is a fascinating place to be and I
think it's a it's a great place as an
editor actually to do stuff that uh you
know isn't you know you you can finish a
trailer in two weeks you know where
you're not on something you can then you
move on to the next one or something but
there's some rewarding part of that
process to to like start something and
finish it like in kind of a quick amount
of time that you that you craft and
create
um as opposed to uh you know working on
something for six months or two years or
whatever you know there's some value in
that part of of the industry for sure
even just that way can you take us
through the process of what it's like to
cut a trailer yeah so uh well I mean the
first step is you watch
down
the series or the film depending on what
it is
uh films I think
sometimes are easier to to cut trailers
for than than television series uh but
I'll get into that in a second for a
film though you basically just watch the
film down you make your selects and what
I do is
um once I've watched that film I usually
like kind of experiment with copy or
um like just like ideas of like what is
you know what am I trying to say because
sometimes you don't have
um somebody telling you like oh we're
going to use this tagline or this
tagline this tagline but you kind of
have an if it's a long trailer in
particular you know you're gonna need it
most often and so you're going to come
up with something as you've watched the
film and then you're gonna play you know
there's library music either uh but you
know obviously trailers are so
uh heavily built around the music so you
obviously have to choose very wisely for
that and the worst Trail uh worst note
that you can ever get is hey the
trailer's great but let's change the
music because really what that means is
you have to redo everything
uh it's just
uh yeah so so there's that and then uh
for television it gets a little more
tricky because you more often than not
don't have the entire full season
uh to cut uh the trailer from
and yet you still have to make it maybe
a minute a 90 second spot uh or trailer
and make it exciting because those
episodes are still coming in they're
still getting delivered because they're
not usually on a really basis I uh at
least in my experience it's always been
that way
so uh you kind of have to get a little
bit more creative sometimes with like
how are you going to rise up at the end
to you know slam dunk this this series
and get people to want to watch it but
that the process is generally the same I
mean you yeah you watch it down you get
your selects you find your music you cut
it together and get your notes back and
then make adjustments and go from there
and um there is usually a process where
once you've done your first cut there's
usually a lot more people uh that get
involved for uh from that moment on
until it gets completely approved
sometimes it's the directors or the show
runners or the executive producers it
just depends depending on what project
it is but there's a lot of hands in it
because it's the marketing of
um their baby or their money maker
whatever it is you know so it's a you
also have to definitely uh know how to
handle criticism and critiques and
um and how to how to be a good team
player basically
sure and is the same process of figuring
out what the note means and applies to
trailers as well yes it definitely does
it always it applies to anything
actually I don't I don't think that
there's any example where somebody's
giving me a note
unless they're where it's like can you
just take two frames off of that that's
when you're like
I'm gonna get a little a little
irritated with you but yeah because that
then that's maybe one note where yeah
that that's really what it means
probably but but how dare you I'm the
editor and I could probably do a little
finesse pass at the end once I know it's
approved uh but you know realistically
though um
yeah any note that you get from anything
whether it's a script it's like it
doesn't matter uh and it you know
trailer there's always usually like
um a general
hey like this is the note and then you
have to be like well is that it or is it
is it like the shot that's before that
or is it the moment before that or is it
the character introduction as I
mentioned earlier like it just you have
to do that part of the process on your
own uh but that is
um I think maybe one of the things that
that always always comes out on top in
the end if you can if you can nail it
figure out what they're what they're
actually getting at
would you see there's more hands
involved at the end of the trailer being
cut or it's consistent throughout so do
they kind of give you an idea show you
what to do like in in terms of what we
want it from this time code to this or
whatever and then lets you run with it
but then toward the end there's all
these hands that get involved or is it
consistent no I think it's it's not like
all these hands all the time it's just
that you usually have some
um
layers to to the uh process as in the
structure of the of the
um the company or the business like or
whatever that you're working with
so
it's not that you have all these people
it's more that you kind of are Pat it's
like you're passing the Donkey Kong
levels
you know like oh okay we got we you know
we got this approval let's go up until
it goes to the top of the company
sometimes even
um you know it just depends but that's
always cool when that happens because
then you're like well yeah like the
president of the company loved my
trailer and then you know you may have
met them you may have not but like it
it's still like you know where that like
people are seeing your work and that's
that's that's pretty cool do you go in
and read the comments just to see did
they like this one section or
once the trailer's online well um oh on
that stuff yeah I did I used to do that
um
not So Much Anymore
um
but also I haven't like you know like I
I did a lot of trailer uh and promo
editing before I did phenom's uh the
soccer series I mentioned so
uh like that was about two and a half
years where I worked at
um Audience Network at DirecTV and ATT
before they closed down and that was
um
one of those like kind of
that was my first time into that world
actually uh where where I kind of got
used to like cutting uh promos for shows
and and how the process even even worked
and stuff but that the cool part about
promo editing and trailers for anybody
who's interested in that stuff is uh
again like I said you know you're on
your your takes a week or two weeks or
you know it's a short amount of time
where you're on one project before the
next one so there's always this kind of
feeling that you're accomplishing
something
uh and then it's it's kind of maybe the
part of the industry at least what I've
found where the hours aren't super
insane
like you know they're more they're kind
of more structured in like a
um this has been my experience and that
you know it's like the least kind of
stressful in that sense versus like
doing production 18-hour days or 16 hour
days or even editorial posts like we're
you know you're you're you're hitting a
schedule on a on a different process and
that doesn't mean that you don't have
long hours and stuff every once in a
while but at least in my experience it
was it was like no this was structured
and it was like a really nice break for
me uh for a while before
um it kind of got crazy again